foreign
in Arlington Virginia what's up Ryan
hey Dr John how are you today I'm good
brother what are you up to man
oh not much a little nervous a little
nervous
I promise I'm more nervous than you
hey um so I got a question for you
um
that question would be
communication skills I'm just gonna get
right to it I have a question and that
question would be all right go ahead hey
we're in it together man what's up uh
all right so my communication skills are
just horrible
um you don't say you don't say I don't
say yeah and it's I feel like it's
interfering with some of my marital life
um and then a little bit in personal
life just with like some family members
and stuff just I'm not I don't know I'm
not able to communicate my feelings that
great
um it's caused a lot of stress I think
in the the marriage sometimes when my
wife
um you know has something that's
bothering her I'm just
I'm not really there for her like I
should be why
um all right let me let me put it this
way communication is a skill set right
it's something we learn and something
you practice and you get better at over
time and you have to have two people
that communicate right one you can't
just be one person dumping into this
endless bottomless pit okay right the
other side of it is the way you're
laying it out for me is that you've got
all the you've got this singular
Challenge and
it's causing problems all through your
life
but you're not doing the little things
like communicating
right so what is not communicating
getting you because it gets you
something
um I I feel I feel safe for not
communicating I guess
what are things you wish you could
communicate that you're not
communicating
uh sometimes my own feelings uh my wife
she she's a little bit of an anxious
person too but
um I feel like sometimes communicating
my thoughts and feelings my
put a big load on her that I don't know
if she
you know is ready to handle or anything
like that so I want to dig into that but
let me say this anxiety is often a
function of disconnection and that's
some nerdy talk to say
if your wife knows something's going on
inside of you she feels that
and when you don't tell her or can't
tell her or shy away from the
conversation
her body starts sounding the alarms that
something's wrong
that something is probably wrong with
her
she needs to fix something so that the
relationship with you is okay and my
guess is that's a pattern that's been a
part of her life for a long long time
because we usually marry our own messes
and so I would suggest the opposite
truly saying what you need and what
you're thinking and what you're feeling
will potentially give her maybe at first
it'll spark it'll it'll it'll put some
oxygen on the fire will make it brighter
and a little bit taller but over time
that it will truly connect you to and
the anxiety will go down
see how this gets self-reinforcing
okay so what are the
what are the things that you're not
telling her what are your thoughts and
feelings that you're holding back
and let me say it this way the only way
through this dude the the way to
practice communication is being honest
and that's not your thing so do it here
yeah yeah
um
say it say it say it
do it
um there are some things like when we we
got married fairly young into the
relationship so like three months of
dating we got married
how old are you a year I'm 30. how long
y'all been married
six years okay
um
a year in their marriage
um we we had our first child and then
fast forwarding to now we've got three
three child so ages five three and one
so a little little bit of stress with
that type of stuff
um but but we love our kids they're
great
you liar you liar go ahead we do levels
we love them until they turn 18 then
we'll be glad to see them go but right
so
um I don't know I just have a hard time
expressing my thoughts and feelings
about seeing certain
certain things like maybe hurt like
she's real close to her family and a lot
of my
values and beliefs don't really go
fully against like what her family sees
things and she it kind of puts her in
the middle of things
um and I feel like if I try to address
those situations then it puts her in a
hard spot to
trying to pick between them or me do you
realize how you're treating her like
your daughter a little bit
you're not you're not giving her things
like this morning my family was is
we're meeting in Los Angeles but they
flew out this morning I'm gonna flew out
flat this afternoon and I my daughter
was trying to carry this big suitcase
and she couldn't carry it down the
stairs and so down into the basement
into the garage and so I carried it down
there for her because I'm her dad and I
got bigger muscles than she does and
that's what you're trying to do with
your wife
your wife's a grown woman she's married
mother of three I would guess she's a
gangster yeah
and when you hold stuff back from her
because you're worried that she can't
then you are you are making come true
what you're hoping isn't going to happen
which is a woman who feels trapped
between somebody who's not being honest
with her and treating her like a kid and
a group of people who are never honest
with her and who treat her like a kid
does that make sense it does
um go back to the beginning
you you
uh
y'all are married
[ __ ] I don't have much of a marriage do
you
all run a daycare center together is
that fair that's very fair okay
your marriage is in desperate need of
y'all two dating each other
because you if you you're desperately
close to I can hear it in you're
desperately close
to turning into roommates if you're not
already or co-workers who in a factory
that makes children
and if you haven't already you are a
spider's web away from Finding Love
somewhere else
and she is too
that doesn't mean you're going to sleep
with somebody else but that means you're
going to become a workaholic that means
you're going to become just that Dad who
just kind of disappears or that Dad who
yells at middle schoolers who are
roughing soccer games
and she's gonna disappear on you too
is that is that fair
yeah yeah that's fair are you already
there
pretty close
uh yeah I think I think we're pretty
close I mean she's told me multiple
times that she just
that she would like to be able to sit
down and talk with me but like I just
don't talk back like I'm just
emotionally not available why do you do
that to her why do you do that to you
and I know asking the why question is
something you're not supposed to ask in
counseling but we're not accounting
session so I'm just going to be direct
like why
why do you shut down
foreign
I get really uncomfortable just trying
to you know talk with people about my
feelings and I like it I don't know like
it doesn't matter or I'm not sure to to
what extent but I just who taught you
that
[Music]
I'm
I was a middle child so you can take
that for what it's worth
um
mom was a little bit anxious but she you
know she supported us and dad was always
real supportive
um I I was always a real shy kid okay
and
um you know I just
was homeschooled up till you know sixth
or seventh grade something like that had
good
friends with the family and who who did
some homeschooling as well then went to
public school and I think going into
public school I just
I was always kind of a smaller guy
um height wise and you know pretty thin
and hearing a lot of comments about that
from like other people sure
um around that age it just made me feel
like a ant in the world yeah
um
so so maybe I mean without without I
mean you and I man we could have 50
different sessions together and hang out
for a while and kind of mine it let's
just take that one that one seems
plausible enough in this short time that
we have together
um you learned really early on from
middle school on you should probably
disappear
or getting small is the best way to get
to navigate tough situations you avoid
ridicule you avoid people making fun of
you you avoid feeling less than like a
loser
just disappear
and now you're sitting across the table
from your wife and mother of your three
kids
and there's nowhere to hide
does that make sense yeah yeah it does
so you've heard me say this a million
times on the show the thing that kept
you safe as a kid is now the thing that
is
set in your marriage on fire and is
setting your parenting ability on fire
because you're passing this along to
your kids too and if you remember that
feeling of feeling small and feeling not
worth your space and feeling like I need
to hide from myself
so that I can avoid detection you don't
want your kids walking through life with
that either and it doesn't start with
you teaching them how to do it it starts
with you doing it standing up taller
speaking and being heard and thinking my
thoughts and my feelings are worth being
heard even when they're hard even when
they're going to cause problems because
right now you're causing problems
right and it feels safe it's kind of
like uh
uh it's like holding your breath on a
roller coaster it feels safe and
eventually you pass out and die
you got to breathe right so at some
point you have this conversation you're
either going to have it around a kitchen
table where you're being honest and open
or you're going to have it with a
divorce attorney
this conversation's coming or multiple
conversations are coming and so here's
my recommendation to you
um
hey let me let me back out a little bit
I've come at you a little bit
I know this is hard
and the reason I'm coming at you is I
just want to shake the snow globe a
little bit and move that sediment from
the bottom
it let you hear me
tell you you are worth being heard
and the best way to help your wife is to
be honest with her the best way to heal
yourself is to be honest with you and
you could have had the best parents on
the planet
and still they say little things like
you're not hurt
you're fine I know you want to eat here
but your brother's whining all the time
so we're just gonna eat here I know you
want to play I know you made All-Star
team but we got to get your sister over
to this thing and so you just learn from
a young age that I matter a little bit
less than everybody else
and
that's going to be the end of you and
your marriage and so let's turn that
sucker around will you commit to that
yeah absolutely okay here is the way I
have navigated this in my life is when I
have to have the thoughts and feelings
conversation especially early on now
it's it's not a thing but especially
early on when I was learning this skill
um I say early on like five years ago so
not not very long ago is I wrote it all
down and there was multiple times my
wife and I read to her while we were
sitting down talking
because I didn't want to miss anything I
didn't want to get loud I didn't want to
get too quiet I didn't want to just be
weird or stumble through so I just wrote
it down and I read it here is what I'm
feeling here's what I think
here's what I need if you start with
just those three things here's what I
feel here's what I think here's what I
need that's a great place to start
okay and then tell your wife we're gonna
send the kids away you you find the
babysitter not her okay you find the
babysitter and say hey we're gonna spend
a couple hours together because I love
you and I think it's fair to use the
language we run a daycare and I'm
interested in being married
and you're all gonna have to date each
other again man you all know y'all never
really dated yeah yeah and I
when's the last time y'all got away and
just had a barn burner romantic weekend
where you couldn't find clothes and the
wallpaper peeled off the hotel room
when's the last time
uh it's it's been probably at least a
year okay
you're worth that for whatever it's
worth
you're also work worth quiet walks in
the woods man like just getting away
doing whatever it is y'all do I'm just
saying man y'all
you'll have to create a life where you
all can be married and then the kids
come in after that not the other way
around
right cool are you in
I mean yeah okay
um start this conversation this way I'm
sorry for being quiet I learned at a
young age to be quiet and I promise to
start being more honest with you start
like that okay
okay and your wife will probably say
where's my husband what'd you do with
him
if this goes terrible and it just goes
like horribly awry holler at me and I
will announce to the world that I failed
you
um but I think if you spend some time
being honest with yourself and writing
stuff down for the first time and then
you read that letter to her and you've
done the hard work of getting
babysitters clearing the deck so that
y'all can have these conversations and
then you say hey I've already got us a
hotel room or I've already got us a date
night and we're gonna start putting on
the calendar
um you start down that road that way and
um
I'm convinced things will turn around
for you thank you for being honest my
man you are among millions of men just
like you trying to figure out what to do
um to help their wives be okay
and it often starts with us just being
honest for the very first time